We've done a bunch of examples
looking at the actual
molecular structure and trying
to come up with the name.
In this video, we'll go
the other way around.
We'll start with the name and
see if we can actually draw
the molecular structure of
whatever this might be.
So let's start.
When you first look at these,
it's very daunting, but you
always want to start really at
the end, so you know what kind
of the core of the structure
is going to be.
So if you look at the end of
this, you have an -ane, so
there's not going to be any
double or triple bonds here.
It's all single bonds.
It's a hexadecane, so let's
think about that.
Hexadec-, that's six and ten.
Hexadec- was a prefix for
16, so this is 16
single-bonded carbons.
And cyclohexadecane, so 16
single-bonded carbons in a
ring, so this part
of it right here.
So let me just do this.
So cyclohexadecane, let's draw
that part first. It's not easy
to draw even a 16-carbon ring,
so let's start here.
One, two, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight, nine, ten,
eleven, twelve, thirteen,
fourteen,
fifteen, and then sixteen.
I think I got it.
Let me count them again and
then I can connect them up
into cycles.
It's one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight, nine,
ten, eleven, twelve, thirteen,
fourteen, fifteen, sixteen.
All right, I drew the
cyclohexadecane part.
Now, if we go back a little,
let's see, we have a
2,9-diisopropyl.
What does this mean?
This means that we have an
isopropyl at the two
and the nine spot.
Now when you are drawing the
structure from the name, you
could just arbitrarily on
someplace on this ring pick
what your one through your
sixteen spots are.
I'll just arbitrarily pick them,
because I could have
drawn this ring any which way.
One, two, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight, nine, ten,
eleven, twelve, thirteen,
fourteen, fifteen, sixteen.
All right, so this next
piece right here, let
me do this in magenta.
2,9-diisopropyl, this is telling
us that at spot number
two and at spot number nine,
I have isopropyl.
The di- is just saying I have
two isopropyls at two and
nine, so you can kind
of ignore the di-.
I have an isopropyl, and you may
or may not remember that
an isopropyl looks like this.
It's three carbons, so it's
going to be one, two, three,
and the connection point to the
main ring in this case is
going to be in the middle
carbon, so it
kind of forms a Y.
All of the isos, the isopropyl,
isobutyl, they all
look like Y's, so it's going to
be linked right over here.
That's also going to happen at
the ninth carbon, so at the
ninth carbon we're going to
have another isopropyl.
We're going to have another
isopropyl at the ninth carbon.
All right, we've taken care
of the 2,9-isopropyl.
Then we have the 6-ethyl, which
is just a two carbon.
Remember, meth- is one, eth-
is two, prop- is three.
Let me write this down.
So this is going to be prop-
is equal to three.
Isoprop- is equal to that type
of shape right over there.
In this case, eth- is equal to
two, so it's a 6-ethyl group.
So at six we have an ethyl
group, so one, two, carbons,
and it's connected at the six
carbon on the main ring.
And then finally we have
a cyclopentyl.
So if we look at-- let me find
a color I haven't used yet--
cyclopentyl.
so pent- is five, but it's five
in a cycle, so this is a
five-carbon ring that's
branching
off of the main ring.
It's at the first spot.
Let me draw a five-carbon rings,
so pent- is equal to
five, so it would look
like this, one: two,
three, four, five.
It looks just like a pentagon.
That's a cyclopentyl group and
it's attached to the one
carbon on my cyclohexadecane,
so it is
attached just like that.
We're done.
We've drawn 1-cyclopentyl-6-
ethyl-2,9-diisop
ropylcyclohexadecane.
Let's do another one.
I think we're getting
the hang of it.
So here, maybe we can do this
one a little bit faster.
Let's see, we have a
tetramethyldodecane, so the
main root here is the
dodecane, do- for
two, dec- for ten.
This is a 12-carbon chain.
It's not in a cycle, so let
me just draw it out.
We have one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight, nine,
ten, eleven, twelve, and so
we can just number them
arbitrarily, just because
I could have drawn
this any which way.
So it's one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight, nine,
ten, eleven, twelve.
That's the dodecane,
all single bonds.
Then we have a
3,6,9,9-tetramethyl.
All this is telling us--
remember, meth- is one carbon,
so all this is telling us is
at the three, the six, the
nine, so at the three, the six
and twice at the nine spot, we
have methyl groups, and we
have four methyl groups.
That's all the tetramethyl
is saying so it's
a little bit redundant.
We know we have four of
them here: 3,6,9,9.
We have methyl groups at
each of those places.
We have one methyl group at
three, and then that is bonded
with the third carbon on
the dodecane chain.
We have one at six bonded
to the six carbon on
the dodecane chain.
We have two at nine, so that's
one at nine and then we have
another one at nine bonded
to the nine carbon on the
dodecane chain.
And we're done.
That's it.
That's 3,6,9,9-
tetramethyldodecane.
Let's do another one.
1,3-bis(1,1-dime
thylethyl)cyclopentane.
So once again, just kind
of breathe slowly.
It's very daunting right when
you look at it, but just start
with the core: cyclopentane.
That's just a simple
five-carbon ring.
A five carbon ring that looks
like a pentagon: one, two,
three, four, five.
There you go.
That is a five-carbon ring.
We can number it however we
want, so one, two, three,
four, and five.
This is telling us at the one
and the three position we
have-- and the bis- is
kind of redundant.
This is saying we have
two of these things.
Obviously, we have two.
We have one at the one
and one at the three.
So you can kind of
ignore the bis-.
That's just the convention
and we've seen
that multiple times.
But at each of those positions,
we have a
1,1-dimethylethyl.
So what's a dimethylethyl
look like?
So let's think about
it a little bit.
Let's think about it and
let me do it orange.
They obviously named it using
systematic naming and what we
have here, we have an ethyl
as kind of the core
of this side chain.
So if an ethyl is equal to two
carbons, so this is two
carbons right there.
So let me draw a two
carbon: one, two.
That is two carbons
right over there.
I'm just drawing it
at the three spot.
I'll draw it also at the
one spot, actually.
So that is two carbons
right there.
That's the ethyl part.
And then on 1,1, so if we number
them, we number where
it's connected, so
it's one, two.
This is saying 1,1-dimethyl.
So on this ethyl chain,
you have two methyls.
Remember, methyl is equal to
one, so this is one carbon.
You have one carbon.
That's what methyl is, but
you have two of them.
You have dimethyl.
You have it twice
at the one spot.
So you have one methyl here
and then you have another
methyl there.
Same thing over here.
You have 1-methyl on the one
spot and then you have another
1-methyl on the one spot.
And then you are connected at
positions one and positions
three, so you're connected there
and you are connected
right over there.
And you're done, That's it.
That is our structure.
Now, if you did this with common
naming, instead of this
group being a 1,1-dimethylethyl,
you might
see that we're connected to
a group that has one, two,
three, four carbons in it.
The carbon that we're connected
to branches off to
three other carbons.
It is a tert-butyl.
So you can also call
this a 1,3-- let me
just write it down.
So another name for this would
be 1,3-tert-- or sometimes
people just write a t there--
t-butylcyclo-- no, actually I
should say di-t-butyl, because
we have two of them.
1,3-di-t-butylcyclopentane.